uh-oh how about now yeah okay
all right hello hey I don't know
somebody sometimes you know people uh
come in here and change things I saw a
bird and went like that hello everyone
audio should work 100% now joined by
Miguel which you didn't can understand
earlier but we're making a character
Metal Gear survived beta is out so if
you want to check that out and join us
please do so you can also download it
for yourself it's not in the wild it's
available until the 22nd right yes quite
a very end of the 22nd yeah so hopefully
I'm pretty sure you guys can hear me now
I'm almost positive but you also got to
check out the like a preview of Metal
Gear survive so I've been blessed to
have you in here with some insight yes
we played a good three and a half hours
mostly with a single player which you
will not that is trippy they can do one
eye
each I've never seen that in a character
creator sorry sorry to cut you off there
is just like I guess it makes sense
though
thank you guys to you in the chapter uh
telling me about the auto sorry I cut
you off go ahead we last week we had the
playing three enough hours of the game
which was mostly devoted to single
player which I hear is not part of this
beta
yeah it's me this is primarily
multiplayer right yeah for the beta so
it's check out our my feelings on it on
GameSpot we cranked out a preview a
couple of videos and our team in
Australia had some news updates
particularly reminding players that
Konami has been quoted that the
single-player will take about 20 hours
to beat and there's gonna be Mike
microtransactions yeah no loot boxes
okay we also reminded fans that the beta
will run until the 22nd and the fourth
thing always online always online yeah
so the game is always online which has
caused some people to be a little bit
unhappy I suppose microtransactions also
causing some people to be a little bit
unhappy but
we can go into into a little bit more
detail of what you saw in terms of
microtransactions I guess yes yeah tell
me about him I guess um well from what
we could tell it wasn't a lot of
clear-cut you know pay-to-win type of
aspects but there were certainly
boosters that we noticed the currency
that you spend before leveling up this
type of like element does a rock called
coup bond the way you go with that
character the way that you earned them
you can actually see get a little get a
little bit of a boost like a twenty
preceding earned them 20 percent faster
there was also this boost called
production boost which whatever
production is in the game we did not
have a chance to really learn about it
but I believe it has to do with the
speed in which some aspects of your home
base which will be pretty big because
like that's kind of like one of the the
draws to down the road is like how you
how your home base is how it's like
built how its protected so here's a
tutorial which will just skim over as
you know what to do you can tell
everyone what to do oh look you have a
gun which apparently you like wasn't
easy to get right oh yes a single player
in fact both me and Matt Espen le
associate editor at GameSpot we despite
how much time we spent on the game we
did not have the resources are your
level 10 suite
okay because we were talking about right
before that you're a little under
leveled in the preview but it's because
the single player level is tied with
your multi player level correct and you
guys only got X amount of time to level
up during that single-player portion of
the preview and then they kind of
thrusted you into the multiplayer which
I think you said yes so we look like
we're of level in theory Oh looks like
Ben's level 12 so we're gonna hit up I
am trying to find the control setup
because its disclosure I'm an inverter
you would be
so
check our inventory so yeah if you guys
have questions for Miguel that he's
allowed to answer I will send him his
way and I just want to say thank you
guys all for tuning in to our game SWAT
live live stream today we have one more
today for you actually because another
beta that was a little wonky last week
and also because it was during the
weekend we couldn't do was Dragonball
Fighters they've come back for a 24-hour
period starting last night at 9 p.m.
Pacific we're gonna actually play that
today me and Joe we're gonna be back on
at 2 p.m. so come by back for that if
you want to see some Dragon Ball
fighters some hot anime and then
tomorrow we're gonna have Monster Hunter
beta the last one before the release
which is next week so a lot of betas
this week right before launch which i
think is cool it gives people the chance
to try some of these games out to test
them out to see if they actually want to
you know invest the you know forty or
sixty dollars forty dollars for Metal
Gear survive this comes out at belief
February 20th correct actual release
whereas like Dragon Ball and whilst
we're going to come out next week I
should pull up our periscope check
probably asking questions there's a lot
there's a lot of people upset in terms
of I'm gonna go into the camera real
quick while you're doing this there's a
lot of people upset about the the shift
the shift in terms of like is not being
Kojima anymore and Konami just kind of
using the platform
I guess so to speak yeah I mean it was a
plus I mean the one thing that was
encouraged about the one thing I was
excited about was the fact that I mean
they're finally finding a way to
repurpose the engine from Metal Gear
Solid 5 which I thought was an excellent
game it almost seems like overdue it's
just too bad that it's not gonna have
you know Kojima involved so yes it's not
an online game only MMA junkie when it
comes out it's gonna be online only and
as you saw there is character creation
so you can try to make your characters
look like Metal Gear characters I guess
to the best of your ability but I don't
think we're there any
iconic figures you could pick from not I
didn't see any no from there was a
tattoo that did remind me of the tattoo
from Vulcan Raven okay I mean I
understand why people could potentially
feel the way they do so it's fine
so you tried joined you're joining been
but it didn't work so we got that hot in
that type three see how this goes if
that doesn't work I might be able to
plug you into something else that'll
probably work so we'll see so there's no
story there's um just like a little bit
right there's no story in the
single-player mode mm-hmm
the care the soldiers from mother base
were mysteriously transported into
another dimension through a wormhole and
you spend the story trying to reunite
with your weaker comrades and finding a
way back home
wormholes play an amusing part as you
play because when you try to capture
animals for eating you you don't summon
them you don't pull them away using the
Fulton balloon system you actually send
them through wormholes gotcha
all right so here we are
zombie diamond Jim head coupon they got
coupon right also if you guys didn't
notice he does actually have like what
it's almost like a stamina bar but it's
not right because it's your oxygen kind
of level below your life right correct
um but you do have to manage stamina and
your oxygen oh okay yes that meter
that's going down as I'm running that's
my stamina gotcha
okay
when you run out I kind of saw you keel
over is it like the old neo where like
you basically stands still and are like
available for attack by anyone or can
you still kind of run around despite
having like no stamina you can't if you
have no stamina you just stop and then
until you get stamina back okay so it is
like old neo where like you got really
punished so it looks like those things
are okay you want to try that camera I'm
gonna try joining our boys session here
we'll see if it works
but yeah this I will agree Camaro Metal
Gear Rising was a good spin-off yeah um
would be cool to maybe get another one
like that I like that the the style and
like the the gameplay style I want to
say it was Peter that would said it'd be
pretty cool to like so that's not
working Ben sorry Ben be pretty cool to
have that like on the switch or
something revengeance agreed yeah and it
did bring to mind a feature that I'm
working on where I'm compiling all the
Metal Gear games that kijima was not
involved can you invite him from here by
chance I'm serious
cuz that just joins right maybe Ben can
try joining on us
did you try sending in my invite earlier
yes it could be our NAT type I could
unplug you and then plug you back in
which I should have probably just plug
you into the other one you know you
might lose connection though for a
second alright surprised online only get
unplugged so fun fact we are of a
corporation and we have a corporate
firewall which gives us this fun NAT
type 3 so anyone that watches giantbomb
also understands the plight that we are
under however we have something in the
works to hopefully combat that in which
case we'll never have NAT type issues
ever again so don't worry Dan Parker
will get to plane we're just trying to
give you a better experience so that
he's not solo necessarily yeah it is
available for Xbox and ps4 so if you
want to check it out go do that okay
what was your what's your history with
the Metal Gear series oh it's very
short-lived to be honest
loved Metal Gear 1 or meadow sorry love
the Metal Gear Solid on the playstation
beat it three times to get the like you
know bandana the cloak and the
spider-man whatever looking and suit
thing try playing to really just didn't
like it and then basically fell off a
cliff after that and then I've dabbled
with revengeance because I'm into like
DMC and that kind of stuff so like
that's right up my alley
like in terms of combat and the gameplay
style but other than that I have not
pretty much have not touched a metal
gear since even though phantom pain I
probably should played anything yeah
family is like really accessible
all right we're okay let's try joining
in if this doesn't work we're just gonna
hop into a game because this is this is
kind of getting thanks for waiting on
Ulis other thoughts from my preview the
one thing I will give the game credit
for they really go all in with the
survive aspect of the game because I was
pretty much spending most of the time
trying to make sure I had enough to eat
and enough to drink and you start off
with some pretty shitty circumstances
because the first time you get water yes
it worked
sorry the first time you get water and
you drink it you're gonna get sick and
you better have some medicine too you
know
so periscope question was will we be
able to get ratings soared as a bonus or
DLC of some sort I doubt that who knows
but dislike to like ratio yeah like I
said there's a lot of people that aren't
necessarily happy with you know the
online-only aspects and the
microtransactions and the fact that you
know Kojima doesn't have a hand in this
you know so I understand why people are
dropped into the dislikes did he try to
make a Meryl is that is that who that is
that's a pretty good Meryl but I think
hey there you are yeah we figured it out
what's up art scene 98 so yeah we're
gonna check out a little multiplayer
session here with our Ben djenka in the
house should be fun time yeah some of
the story missions I also play decided
when I wasn't busy trying to forage for
food and water
by the way you also need to if you want
clean water yes you have to find the
materials to craft a kettle
yes I didn't even get to do yeah cuz
otherwise the dirty the water is dirty
and it kind of like makes you sick right
yes Watson stars be honest are they
paying you to promote this no actually
they are not we are allowed to say
whatever we want good or bad we're just
checking out the beta we check out a lot
of betas on gamespot live Oh looks like
Ben Stein walloped I wonder if they
could share that so Dion Lewis asking do
you like this game
I'm lukewarm on it so far okay and that
that was like roughly what two to three
hours of playing three hours okay and
that was a combination of single-player
as well as multiplayer it was about 80%
single-player gotcha
lots of like RPG style like fetch quests
we had to pick up some mutter boar
motherboards from these abandoned bases
well they weren't really abandoned they
were just infested all right been
finding materials I mean not managing my
stamina well is there any way to cut it
is there like a trick or anything to
like kind of manage that stamina better
or like you know like run when you
drinks or anything because I remember
like Final Fantasy 15 there was like a
weird trick for like running and stuff
like that if I'm not mistaken from what
I got I just need to be very efficient
with pick those nails and would I need
to be very efficient with my running TJ
I'm Matthew 29 yes it is free for
anybody so yeah the game comes out in
February it's a $40 how big is the map
ask Leon a crop I think Aaron krob um
that's a very good question I mean in
terms of that's a fine yes thank you Bob
sorry
you're so sorry you're talking about the
map sighs um before I rudely interrupt
it's okay Lutz something that's I mean
in terms of this mode this is the map
okay but it's a it's a defense type
mission the story mission map it's it's
much much larger than this I can tell
you that so this is the that is this the
where you're being told to go is
basically where you're defending correct
okay I mean that would hopefully this
will help in giving me enough materials
to build fences nice so if you guys have
seen any footage of the fences it's like
a good way to kind of walk out the
zombies while using like your spear here
to kind of fill them through the fence
danger
how many enemies did you say you've seen
I've seen like this kind of like normal
kind of dude I've seen like the bomber
we probably running to see that they
show them a certain way I've seen about
like maybe like five zombie types
thankfully none of them are fast moving
if you find yourself very low on stamina
just give yourself a breath and I had no
problems escaping from any of the
zombies when I was this is like a it's
like a standalone game correct yes yeah
so it's a complete kind of like on its
own thing Mario $40 you should be able
to find it right now TJ TJ am probably
in this store
sometimes it's like I get personally
more on PlayStation sometimes it's a
little bit more tricky to find some of
these free betas like Dragonball
fighters had to go to like free or
something instead of like searching for
it sometimes doesn't get you the beta so
just peruse around you I'm sure you'll
find it okay I need to learn how to
actually make fences because right now I
do not have that ability okay unless I
want to rely on Ben no I think that you
guys it can't just be Ben
but oh here we go see defense units I
have no defense units let's find a way
to build them something with the fence
icon give me that fence icon advanced
workshop can you make it here a wooden
fence I saw cool fence okay some fences
oh it just takes coupon energy is that
what it is yes and it looks like that
pool is shared between you and bends so
that's good
turrets you're missing a lot of parts
wow so yeah I mean this shows like how
much oh it's about to start
where's that at oh he built some fences
or does that already populate once the
digging starts I'm sure maybe Ben did
actually build space right here good ol
Ben always on the case here oh he's got
bone arrow and you live in that poverty
life that's spear life yes the spear is
the first thing that you can get and
machetes one of the first things you can
craft but I like the spear because of
its range okay so you were saying you
and Matt we're saying that it reminds
you this this game type here in
multiplayer reminds you a lot of
fortnight or just an yeah I mean only
because fortnight is the first thing I
think of when it comes to these kinds of
like base defense games but honestly
there are many many other types of games
like this who he's sniping from a
distance here you are standing on the
frontlines not even behind the fence I
feel like you're looking for trouble now
he's gonna have to cover another door
yeah Ben I don't necessarily have this
side covered but can you fault an
extraction stuff kind of yes it started
through war it says 200 armed oh yeah oh
Lord
Wow yep nailed it you sure you want to
be out here probably not I mean you're
you're free to play however you want I
feel like you're making a bold choice
here I don't have the reach now all you
have is that in the machete I think that
uh
yeah get stabbed
Oh Ben's crazy he just got knocked out
or a wall yeah punch this game needs a
battle royale mode uh TTT be careful
what you wish for I feel like like oh oh
Lord
get out of there I feel like 20 oh he's
dead does this go in well Miguel all
because you guys aren't using your
defenses I don't know why you guys are
going Yolo I thank God be careful what
you wish for with battle rail I feel
like 2018 is gonna be the year of Battle
Royale like you know last year I feel
was the year of the hero shooter and a
couple years before that was the year of
MOBAs so he doesn't even realize he has
a gun yeah do you actually have a gun do
you know what you probably is not used
to it because in the preview bill
should be open beta cane the one I'm not
mistaken I'm sure someone will tell me
if I'm incorrect but I'm pretty sure
secondary weapons
there we go
yeah it's true war machine guy people
are still gonna buy it dislikes don't do
anything yeah but the people the
internet like to hit that like or just
like one that's just how it goes the
beta is free Allen pears you should be
able to get on and play it now are you
doing the double-layer
as you are
karinch wave one of three so is it only
three waves for this mode yes
when did the the big bombers start
showing up
I think wave too nice we're gonna have
some fun then yeah well take those
bottles oh it's got clean water that's
good
ooh gun is that gun crafting station do
you write yes pick everything up
thanks Robert McCready fine words pile
of goods gunpowder man it's good for
bullets I'm not sure if the beta is on
PC been Jo
maybe someone chat knows it will be I
think we released on PC though
yes that is correct crafting this ammo
itself where is the regular gun crafting
Oh is that just a mo yes
might as well get some ammo yeah
and we're starting soon get ready for a
zombie defense mobile hero shooter
battle royale game to rule the markets
so you're saying maybe paladin's yeah
they're gonna have their hero shooter
that's gonna have a battle royale mode
and the twist is that it's a hero
shooter
ooh what's he got oh he's got some clean
Wars or something oh he's got flame trap
Hot Diggity damn get roasty-toasty up
there's a bomber
f off I don't know if it's on Steam yet
look at this
marksmanship lining it up I notice it
does have a weak spot though right oh
the weak spot back right was it okay
yeah so like from what I saw in the
video like you gotta have to sneak up to
these guys and then they have a weak
spot on the back of their neck and if
you stab it they don't blow up and they
just died but if anything they're
blowing up your defenses
you might get explode it by that I'm not
sure well find out you can't get my
offense
you're just a bomber
watch out okay so it gives you time to
get out of there before disintegrates
it's good because it also blows up the
other guys which is get that little
wombo combo going on what cut all mgs
without Kadeem is blessing
how long do you until you think we
actually see some des handing like
gameplay 20/20 I'm thinking game play
next year
really yeah III III next year yes
get off me get punished ooh right in the
leg there's a nice time to say that this
game does is it does have a chorus class
and character progression system
I suspect that at some point I will be
able to have actual CQC moves oh you
think so yes oh yeah I did see you kind
of leveling up your characters but you
do that in single-player right correct
and again because of the of the always
online aspect of the game your
progression does is shared through both
single-player and online
that is true there's been a couple metal
gears as bread or decide has mentioned
that didn't have gajima on them that'll
cure acid revenge in some portable ops
and sneaks revenge on the NES oh wow the
next wave so soon I'll end a way whoops
I need learn to read I think one just
got through somehow oh just kidding we
survived that's interesting so it's it's
time based on both not necessarily yeah
and not necessarily the fact that like
there's still monsters that are coming
through one thing that is I am glad
about despite the fact that the gate
this game does have food we are not
needing to watch our food at least not
in this mode now this mode it might be
in the final version of the multiplayer
but it is definitely a huge component in
the single-player it is constantly
depleting equip this
taking all the ammo out of the storage
huh yeah don't even want to make any I
made some been saying this is more
difficult than I thought it would be
that's good well Ben you're holding your
own thanks for helping
okay so I suspect that the actual
firearms I need to craft in the lobby
okay we can check that out after I guess
yeah
nice you covered a lot of materials it's
nice to know what the paths of the
incoming enemies are I mean I don't
think the game needs to be that
transparent but maybe it's because it's
easy mode yeah don't
you'd be surprised I feel like
I mean for all the people that uh I
would say are doubters right now which
is fair I would say since it's a free
beta should probably check it out before
you know passing final judgment other
than what you're watching it's out there
for a reason and the beta is free so I
am not sure if it's out beta wise though
on PC so apologies I'm pretty sure it's
not I think x-box and PS work correct
and how do you make a flame trap and you
can't about to start tickety-tock here
we have miguel making fences Wow been
legit making some traps that's fine you
gotta you got to have the fences to it
to stop them from getting into the base
yeah like triple-layer
um where I'm hole there I'm surprised a
lot of people mentioning that they wish
they did something else other than like
a zombie type game with the engine it's
fair also exciting that you know they're
just tired of zombie games that one
zombie game looks cool though the was it
he threw your video game awards it was
like GTFO I don't know you got me of
like left for dead like the like new
version of left for dead i guess i heerd
spied like the payday developers I think
so I think that one looks cool but who
knows they don't go around it at all the
ones I've encountered hey there's a
fence but there's also a side path
around it that's fine alright doing work
there solid shed geo there on the digger
already yes they're going to town on the
digger
oh there's an armored guy now oh and
there's a bomber oh this is not good
thank you guys kill the bomber oh you
see it so you see that little oval shape
that is the weak spot of the bomb when
you're out of bullets slap em off mmm
the bomber exploded on the bigger we're
still good oh wait there's an armored
guy was there like a dropkick okay and
that axe is pretty good for it like AoE
dude you guys got a minute 35 and
there's not too much light flags been on
the can you build fences around the
bigger
that's hilarious actually
and get to that sense
oh they're climbing I haven't seen that
Oh
[Music]
these are smarter one minute Oh get away
get away get away get away I think your
fences toast though yep that fence is
toast
Oh oh man are you guys gonna last 45
seconds I'm gonna go with a hot most
likely not but uh you guys can prove me
wrong he's getting destroyed - they
might beat there on the digger oh man
this is this is real sketch come on
15 seconds it's almost like no armored
guy comes I feel like you'll be all
right ten seconds
I'm not a fan of the friendly that was
friendly fire right he swung the axe and
I think he knocked you down with it Wow
talk about I think you can have up to
four people Leon krob you got you guys
go pretty look I'm just saying what's
the iris energy that's I can't very good
question this foursome learning about it
take that arrow up you can't sweep can
you look up the sky
send that energy back it's like sending
it to Goku first beautiful what time is
the Dragon Ball stream 2 o'clock oh
what's that
what do we get you got some high voltage
batteries got TNT gears nylon fiber but
I hope that was sure we could share that
stuff it's not so I gotta be surprised
wow really
that's generous that was like more like
it oh is that more stuff right there
this game I feel like it was more like a
D effort one of the there's one more
behind you to one of the difficulty
ramps up if depending on how many
players it's got to write tarragon we're
gonna be making some food Oh is there
like purple drops yes and I guess what
oh there's gold like legendary yeah okay
okay okay he dumped up their score there
but you know he's higher level that's
alright we're learning day one oh I
can't wait for the Dragon Ball shame
yeah we should be pretty good I think
like the continued I had a little bit
trouble getting matches last night not
too bad and it just in terms of how long
it took me to get a match but once I got
a match it started to kind of trickle
trickle down so should be good super
good excited about that game alright
maybe you can craft here oh you got a
machine gun nice no expiration we got
gadget slings and got shotgun there's
some arrows what is going on you got
well I have let's see actual God like a
random recipes right sweet Crassus is
there anything you can craft
I hope so
yeah must be is it that always leveling
up skill trainer
let's get so this is the first class
that you have it's called survivor I
don't know the names of the three other
classes but there are total four classes
boom level up you have two skill points
now which I guess you can a lot more
correct yes okay so we actually have a
gallery an article on these of these
survivor classes on gamespot cool what
are you gonna get I always like let's
see I always like prioritizing stats
over specialized abilities okay I always
felt there was an opportunity for like a
feature on like what what you tend to
fill up on the skill tree says a bunch
of personality like in a racing game up
a type of guy who favor is like
acceleration over other stats alright
now what else do we have here is that
the workbench oh yeah it's like the
matrix
[ __ ] just shows up mm-hmm we go oh
there's that axe that he made I have the
tools for the X well okay well I say
maybe you should have held off but
that's fine I just said that because
maybe there's other stuff you wanted to
craft and you need the materials for it
but that's fine well it looks like there
isn't I think in the law I enjoy my the
reach of the spear so I think I'm going
to its Lobo I would say depending on
where you're looking for it like if
you're on ps4 I searched like the free
section see if it's in the free section
or like the what's hot now section
usually the newer stuff shows up there
sometimes searching for it isn't good
enough you wanna go look at some of
these other workbenches
I got a Joel infinite bullets though in
the loading area oh he's gonna give it
back to you with shotgun oh that's right
yeah shouldn't have messed with Ben we
need to figure out how he got that
shotgun on because I'm assuming you have
it too right I have the means
oh you can craft armor too right so what
that is over there ooh
cowboy hat a balaclava that's a mask
Daniel a tactical scarf what do you want
to make highest defense diamond dog
gloves we're definitely making something
right you gotta upgrade here okay
chestrig I think we got enough to make
some more to you some other stuff
so we're not wearing just motherbase
stuff
yeah we're deaf okay I'm not even go
into that age dawg
I find that hilarious though nothing
okay he thinks that us an IGN are gonna
give this game a 10 a 10 and Game of the
Year no I don't even know why I read
that just type in name press X on metal
gear survive scroll down the demo on
download for free
yeah you got a scroll that about like
two pages worth in the game store that's
good to know
the game page yeah so yeah this
intestinal medicine was huge when I was
drinking dirty water nice dirty water
oil trap trap yeah what we need to
figure out is where Ben grabbed his
shotgun from cuz you got some of that
stuff too I think
I'm not mistaken because remember we saw
those packages with like the AR and
stuff correct it might actually change
equipment it also might be yeah my
repository - okay got ya
and yeah I mean it can be it seems like
a little bit of work to just I mean
fetch items from your repository and
then equip it but guess it's organized
if anything
oh you need to change your equipment
mm-hmm oh you already had that stuff so
we didn't even you make it I guess I
should have been a lot more thorough
checking the store or maybe it was like
Ben's collection yeah my pouch manager
maybe it's in the marriage positions
Oh sledgehammer he's got the target
practice is up oh he's got the AR - we
need the AR go get the AR I don't know
how he got to it but we need to grab
that assault rifle - you could then was
it in the repository supply box it's
it's blinking I can only assume that
it's in there yeah give me that give me
that give me that am mrs for and a rasp
TBS G and a revival pill which seemed
pretty important last time for you guys
because you guys died yeah they got sent
to me as daily I just I figured it out
probably wanna grab that ammo to Ben
after he picks this stuff up you guys
should queue up to another using heavy
arrows flame arrows little slow sorry
guys
you'll get recipe here
it's Lobo if it's not in the search well
so I think Miguel said you had to go
down like two pages to get to it if it's
not there like I said it's got to be
somewhere else there's always other
places so alternatively you can search
for it online on PSN and log into your
account to your browser and then buy the
game there and then it should show up in
your library I got the air-cannon
recipe alright
I'm building that air cannon I doubt you
have enough for their cannon
you're right yes all right can you cue
the mission yes I'll make sure I have
actually my weapons doesn't look like it
saw the and there's a shotgun
I saw the AR there for a second was in
the first primary was the hip I totally
saw it though thought to
I'm pretty sure is on the first menu
though I feel like no no you're you're
there yeah yeah there you go am i
dropping all right the bow assuming you
can't drop the go for it
oh you might have to keep the spear or
the hammer and then go and take a gun
instead of the axe oh gosh Wow
okay I would not keep bow and arrow all
right cool let's do it
sorry Ben no we're nothing oh it's
probably that other one where he's at
we'll try this oh yeah a deserted mine
we'll do normal yeah we're doing normal
we're not doing anything but normal
Oh Ben likes the bow for all the ammo he
can make for the bow that's fine we're
just on a stream ban we're gonna use all
that Ambo nishan and one ition
ammunition yes open beta Mila May on
consoles Xbox one as well as peace war
do you do not have to pay for the beta
it's free it's open oh oh they're level
20 mistakes were made mistakes were made
Kayne the one keep searching maybe you
guys shouldn't use revival pills here
yeah
you gotta be collecting stuff man
you're right look at all that praise
that Ben's getting who's steal yeah give
us that bundle of Steel all of it one
yep swiping animate swipe it woo
chromium steel and tungsten alloy this
is the [ __ ] right here this this little
room has been a gem so I wonder if ego
theoretically just like gather all this
stuff and then just leave probably I
mean like what's stopping you if I had a
ps4 next to me to check Caine the one
I'd do it for you but like they said it
might be on the next page of it or you
could try doing it on website the PSN
website the other thing is like I said
try checking like the free section or
like the what's hot now section and like
kind of scroll through that I feel like
it's got to be in there
got some iron from that bucket
should I get this game when it comes up
ass Brian I think that you should play
the beta for free now see if you like it
and then base your decision solely on
that I can't make that decision for you
obviously I don't know how much of a
Metal Gear fan you are if you're into
survival games if you are in your
survival games and it'll gear probably
up your alley
but there's an interesting icon that
looks like this wait and maybe there's
also I think you might be encumbered
based on like how much stuff you have
we can't even assassinate these dudes to
kill them that's that's fun this is
going to be interesting that's what Ben
says Erin Roberts also saying it's in
the demo section so try finding it there
good luck to you guys
in these wandering uppercut wow that's
good like nothing that tickled them okay
all right these guys won't anytime we're
in a problem so when there's a bunch of
them what I would say Ben is are were
you playing with others yes we're
playing currently with one of our
co-workers Ben djenka I think what we
should do here is just try around any of
you guys get gived right away maybe just
go back to the other map because you
guys are severely underleveled so this
one is not like pub G Twitter gossip
there's no at least as of now there's no
battle royale mode it's just this
multiplayer kind of like for defense
multiplayer and then there's also a
single-player where you know it's more
of a survival game plus crafting and all
that stuff
being told that the size of the demo is
roughly eight gigs by our Chris Pereira
thank you I think that's I think that's
silly though that like you could hit Ben
cuz like I don't know maybe that no
maybe maybe it's supposed to be more
realistic and I'm I'm the I'm the crazy
one
keep my fences have you fault into
anything okay I've Fulton in the single
player okay if there are animals in this
game
hello Karen K now I haven't seen any
animals there's a flame trap I'm not
sure how many maps are our lucky yes
we're on like the second of I don't know
if you based it off just like the UI
maybe it's like six or seven I like I'm
just trying to remember from the picture
of my head that I just saw but I'm not
sorry and don't know the actual exact
number of maps dang so that camera is
pretty good obviously it's a little
slower but time to D up time to D up
where are you gonna put some some fences
we go
right in front all right here we go
it's so silly what is the main story of
the single player asks Raman Rasul it's
technically like a spin-off to phantom
pain your mother base plus all the all
of venom snake soldiers ended up getting
pulled into this wormhole and they're in
this other dimension and they're just
trying to find their way back home will
light destroy this fence with my
sledgehammer yes you will okay I'm
almost positive he was so I would say
try to keep it up for now and help them
or hit them you didn't hear that
well it's kind of cool that the
sledgehammer oh I don't know if it was
just in this case but like kind of had
armor from like the guy hitting it a
little bit so you can actually still
have an attack in Oh slam dunk just so
you know you're pretty low on health
okay oh you can hop the fence yes Oh
need some food or something
after you kill this guy or get hit by
him
do we want to revive here I don't think
we want to revive here just watch
then get mauled you can do it Ben oh
he's doing some dolphin diving buoy
shotgunning um now oh you redeploy in 40
seconds though can bend survive 40
seconds while protecting the deck that's
the question oh I like how that guy's
slowly falling down on the oh you serve
up nope he died alright so suggest
suggest that you make sure that your of
or close to the level because you know
when the monsters are 20 in years like
12 things hurt a bit so
run rocks 26 asking does the game seem
as controversial playing it as the fans
of the series say I don't know it's
there's nothing i know it's
controversial in sense that I mean at
least earn a loot boxes is that where
we're going to though
Miguel at least there wasn't loot boxes
is that a thing that people are gonna be
able to say at least there was no I mean
I'm not gonna yeah I'm just so you're
lukewarm about the game but like just
because it has the metal gear tag on it
doesn't isn't like making or breaking
the game for you right I mean like do
you have expectations because of that
I'm hoping there's gonna be I mean
there's there's obvious like metal gear
elements that can't that can't be
ignored I mean the it definitely feels
like it was built off the phantom pain
engine just like the UI I just like the
little touches about the very familiar
sound effects little things like that
but I'm not expecting actual like
serious story developments that you know
I'm gonna consider to be canon let alone
any kind of like cameos but it's not
unprecedented for a Metal Gear spin-off
i mean i know i mean--can treatment was
not involved in the Game Boy Advance
game or I mean he was he didn't direct
it at least and there were also the acid
games all right here we go back to the
level we know we can beat and hopefully
beat with not just a little bit life
left on the rigger yeah I mean as you
had mentioned earlier it's not like the
first game to kind of take a franchise
name and spin it off as something else I
know that does upset a lot of people but
again like I said the the beta is free
it's it it's out there in the wild you
can play it you should decipher if you
like the game based off of that instead
of just hating on it because it's not
Kojima it's like you're upset that
they're using you know
the Fox engine and the metal gear kind
of like phantom pain and reusing it for
other purposes I can understand like
being upset but like in herds on an
actual game let's say go try it out see
if you like it if you don't or if you're
just so upset that they've done this to
a game or a franchise that you like so
much then ignore it and just let it beat
and enjoy the Metal Gear games that
you'd like and and we'll leave it at
that
you know but like I said the game the
bait is out for free yep all the time in
the world as long as do you have an Xbox
one or Playstation 4 sorry PC to try it
out and make your own kind of judgment
on if you think you're gonna play it in
February asthma as meta Spinelli and I
mentioned in our video we're more
curious than excited it's it's so it
feels so unfamiliar in the sense that
you're playing this very for lack of a
better word basic metal gear like
soldier who does not have all the skills
of of the snakes we've played as in the
past in fact it seemed very superhuman
for snake in the phantom pain to have
this unlimited stamina and now you're
just a normal super super limited Oh
nope okay not breaking that
oh yeah and I should add and I'm
surprised I forgot this apparently there
are gonna be some rewards in this beta
if you spend a lot of time with it that
will actually carry over into the main
game that's cool
so more incentive to play the beta right
and you really have to wind that thing
up before they get closer right ooh
dodged it that coupon oh there's some
this is I think this is what like helped
you level right correct it's what you
spend for leveling we don't need it we
don't need it in some of the missions
you infiltrate these zombie infested
bases and while you can just ignore many
of the zombies and is head straight for
the item that you need to get to
complete the mission the fact that the
zombies drop koo-koo bond will
incentivize you to try to kill as many
as you can for your leveling ask you
this is new alright so I got some cuts
and I'm gonna use some my septic kit to
heal up are you there because
you actually have the item for it
apparently had five okay I'm healing
myself right now
I stopped bleeding now
everything I need
okay
build some fences
feel like you guys will do better this
time it's just a feeling I have kind of
setting you up for failure though but
thanks yeah how it goes thank you guys
all for tuning in on YouTube twitch
periscope
GameSpot's we are live every day at
11:00 if you guys didn't know that we're
gonna have a bonus stream today at 2:00
p.m. with me and Joe we were playing
dragon ball fighters because they did
they added one more day of beta before
the release of that comes out next week
and then tomorrow we'll be checking out
Monster Hunter beta the last one also
before game released next week I'm still
in the fence if I want to be am on hunt
Monster Hunter hard to say that's a time
commitment for sure
okay
now you can also play this solo I think
you were able to get into a map earlier
by yourself
also there is single-player the only
caveat is that it is always online so
just know that I'm surprised they
haven't mixed up the path where they
come from yeah oh we were using
gonna burn your bullets now no they need
to yet but you know you do you how many
plays per round as Daniel dev I believe
it's for up to four
I'm gonna shoot him through the fence
there now on fire oh they are melting
boy he is also four levels higher this
is this is the thing that that perplexes
me though that there there there is a
path but they just will go into the
fence despite there being a path around
he'll be smarter in the harder
difficulties
man you guys are so strong that you're
just gonna go kill them all this would
have been nice to have a little 15 there
I think little 15 map in there in
between the tenets is horny that's true
now I feel like you're too strong for
these guys and Ben's gonna have like
quadruple might whatever my score is
yeah because he's killing everything
sledgehammer so slow yeah it's slow but
it definitely does the DPS oh here goes
Miguel he's like you got flame arrows I
got machine gun ooh he's going for
accuracy - he's not even spraying oh oh
here comes the fire arrows I'm been
djenka I think the I think I'm like in
the axe got good AoE flame arrows looks
like it's also got good AoE should be on
Xbox Live as well see you rod you should
be able to get that so check that out of
here if you want to check it out
homerun oh there's a side mission
ammunition resupply won't you go do that
there's a big blue bubble to your left
oh well now you're yeah so it looks like
there's some side things you can do and
if you do them I guess you can get like
a higher score or maybe some new some
material or a loot or something cuz
there's this did this come off last time
I don't recall it coming up if it did
became the last time I think Ben might
have did it yeah pick that up what's in
that box
what ammo container okay oh you're done
then just gotta bring it back now I
guess
usually when I finish these side cause
there's like some indicator however late
I completed at least when the single
player is concerned okay cuz like on the
map it's not blinking anymore which is
interesting
you at the point you have to bring it
back
yeah the character creator was break
will add a lot of different things you
could tweak had a decent amount of like
different heads that you could pick from
we didn't go too crazy here we go yeah
see so you just got come back so that's
good probably adds to your overall score
at the end try to get that S rank
best place to know Nikolas neck Metal
Gear survived is gonna be on Xbox one as
well as PC currently the beta is only on
ps4 and Xbox one
so we got two more waves here probably
gonna call it a stream after that so if
you have any questions for Miguel who's
seen some single-player as well as play
the multiplayer why don't you fire those
off in the chat and I will try to send
him over his way we also have some
footage that we answers we have some
footage we captured ourselves from the
single player on GameSpot shows a number
of our the missions that we took on you
know we were disappointed that many of
the missions did feel like chores but
again it was part of the onboarding
process and there's gonna be a lot of
onboarding in the game because we
actually started on chapter 3 winded up
all the way to chapter 4 and yeah we
were spending most of our time just like
building our bases getting used to like
how the world works learning all this
craft annexes yeah
now we coming from four directions
you just go to a spot that he's not at
for that oh oh so he sneaked out
whatever pretty sure you can sneak up on
those guys and like okay or bench is
gonna go to see that a little weak spot
on his neck don't be near that I think
you can assassinate that damn it man I'm
trying to make a point to the stream
that thing that little thing on his back
you see it was a crit spot right yeah
see and it doesn't blow up there you go
thank you thank you bet that's one for
our how-to Survival Guide
yeah make sure to find the weak spots
all those critical spots
of course he's using flaming arrows
there's more coming I know they come to
attack home run
kind of wondering how complex it gets
later because like you had that air
turret thing right so maybe there's
stuff that flies
Holy's did that take up stamina I don't
think it did right this way nothing so
how do i download metal gear survive you
either go to the demo section and
download it from there or try searching
for it and supposedly it's like two
pages down unknown soldier' asking for
our thoughts on it so far may I haven't
played it personally watching it I don't
know I am don't particularly care for
like a horde mode kind of the wave
defense thing the single-player survive
stuff sounds interesting but I could
also see where I personally would be
frustrated but maybe with your friends
it could be a good time you know just
hop on do a couple of maps together I
hate saying that all the time but you
know games are so generally in most
cases or some cases at least games are
better when you're playing with your
buds a state would like monster hunter
like I'm sure Monster Hunter world's
gonna be fun by yourself but like the
hunting a monster with like three other
people is probably gotta be a better
experience so that's my personal take on
it without having played much what are
your thoughts so far I'm playing the
beta and also I guess playing a little
bit single-player like I think you had
mentioned lukewarm but you can get I
mean I'm itching to learn to like really
get into the meat of the story again we
spent so much time in the story just
learning about how the game universe
works and how our home base how to build
up our home base or everything from like
a cooking station to all these crafting
stations and the leveling up station
really and the interesting thing is I
mean I know we started this map with
like our gas masks on but for some
reason we're picking between waves maybe
or that was there was dust there and
it's an interesting in the story you
only meet your gas masks when you go to
particular parts of the map these air is
called the fog and normally that's you
have to watch your o2 levels
I noticed now that the food and thirst
icons are actually appearing right now
obviously it's not it's not an issue
right now but
in the single-player you have to spend a
lot of time managing your health and
thirst yeah I mean also too we're only
scratching the surface if you look at
the skill tree it looks a little bit
more extensive than what we can actually
get to at least just starting now
there's more moves you can spec into
there's only like one of the four
classes I think that you have mentioned
or I want to check out some of the other
class trees and what you can level up
that's on gamespot
say in gallery form so easy to kind of
just peruse like what it would be like
the level if you wanted to do that I
mean I'm here's how all the different
classes if you have like a group of
friends and you guys like diversify and
do like a different class per person how
that I I mean it presumably like helps
yeah I'm sure I'm sure there's there has
to be some type of benefit and even if
there isn't like necessarily a party
benefit or like a benefit between
players it's just like a different play
style experience so it's just like try
to find the one that you like the most
so this trip
no way to figure out what what paths
they're gonna take well you can always
put in here the digger but I guess the
guys are so powerful right now that you
don't need how can i play on xbox beta
you need to go to the store and then
probably search for the demo is my guess
I haven't actually personally looked for
it on Xbox so I can't specifically tell
you how to do it but it's definitely
should be there here coming through the
wormhole the armored guys just for him
huh one flame trap just for him
we are currently playing on my ps4
there's a whole bunch of guys oh boy
bomber over there - Oh Molly gotta find
that weak spot
oh the flame arrow just doing absolute
work steal his kills
yeah steal those kills they might be on
fire but you're not finishing a mob I'll
kill the armored guy you'll forget a lot
points nice 30
dan we're doing a way better job than
last time just gotta say it also helps
that you have an assault rifle though I
suppose and the flame arrows that Ben
had also probably but a bit and my one
handicap is that I'm playing normal
instead of inverted
oh that's very that's true I totally
forgot that you haven't switched your
controls that gives you a mildly
annoying actually very annoying I hate
when people switch it to invert and I'm
like what
oh bomber you're also better
me capsule oh yeah Oh Ben Ben died died
of that we almost laid an intricate trap
for our partner you got a sledgehammer
it or get something oh oh yeah here we
go
BAM
hey you
we gotta get s ring get off our digger
wait am i beating up
excuse me we will push this down
Vince is still good barely lifespan on
your 100 kills really it's at that oh I
said top right dang that's good work
darn it you're so close to dropping the
hammer on them
Oh been on that pixel life
home run
keep trying to [ __ ]
or wormhole oh you teleporting oh okay
that's how I never played around with a
wormhole alright well you can teleport
to another spot boom
nice work I don't think you're gonna get
it oh wait no you guys are almost at s
does that whole meter have to be filled
to get the s probably has to be filled
yeah we were so close to an s alright
just on a ps4 normal dang we were so
close to that s rank and you're still
bleeding despite it being post game
personal score 31 70 who knows what uh
boy binge Hank over there got all the
boxes young I think I think Ben got at
least five digits whoa
got a na get that orange box broken
survival Bo two of them the orange box
is a nice Metal Gear Solid 2 yeah homage
strings our Springs rather jeez that's a
lot coupon we need that coupon for
leveling I think the last thing we'll do
is like have you go through the skills
tree level up a little bit and
white-collar stream just so you guys
know we're streaming again later today
in about an hour and thirty minutes
we'll be playing during well fighters oh
he's got a little roll oh yeah gerbil
gerbil gerbil meet like how it's like
terrible but it doesn't say durable me
even though it's clearly humbly if you
want to find out for yourself if you are
gonna enjoy the game or not you can just
download the beta ps4 or Xbox one I held
my own hen-coop says loot box have made
it into the game come on in sick alright
we're gonna continue the game this is
like the lobby area before you head in
well once it loads you'll see the fun
stuff as for marmoset is mgs5
multiplayer but with co-op
and zombie survival balloon trap sure
and a turret recipe
all right so here's the skill trainer
we got a lot we got 129,000 we're gonna
be leveling up quite a bit here okay all
right so you got three points so this is
one of the four four classes you said
write this survival Survivor sorry see
well this is very good for my
sledgehammer I need to actually wait it
looks like I got to fill these up before
I could actually access these no no you
have them filled you got ministry so now
it's the next tree yeah thank you - no
worries
I'm here for stomping stomping would be
good get stomped cqc counter there's
anything to get you closer and closer to
actually moving and quickly leg sweep
sweep the leg
but what sensei I said so yeah there's
also crafting but if you want more
in-depth discussion in terms of like
single-player and some multiplayer our
Matt Espinel II as well as Miguel
concepción they talked about their time
with the preview but this man is out on
Xbox as well as ps4 so you guys can go
ahead and download it it's free it's an
open beta run so I believe the 22nd is
always said correct and I believe the
game comes out February 20th is the
scheduled date for $40
so definitely probably want to check out
that beta I'm playing trap been in the
empty department store nice you
definitely want to check out that beta
if you're interested at all I understand
there's a lot of people that are not
necessarily happy with the fact that
Kojima is not on here and or the
microtransactions and or the online-only
but hey you never know sometimes you
play a game and you end up liking it
sometimes you don't but at least you get
it to try it so check that out and see
if you like it come back at a two
o'clock which is in about an hour and a
half to watch me and Joey
getting on some of that Dragonball
Fighters beta last one right before the
release thank you so much for playing
today we go no problem thanks for
joining guys any last thoughts still
curious and not too excited yet but I am
very very interested to playing the full
version both single-player and
multiplayer I would definitely love
everyone's thoughts on the the story
component to see if it's like even holds
up to what Kojima has done in the past
sounds good thanks guys and see you guys
shortly actually bye bye alright